gones à coups de gueule de géraldine
maillet oui contre netflix
dexia a annoncé cette nuit qui mettait
fin à la série halo sauve car c est
suite à l' annonce de kevin spacey enfin
kevin spatial non ça c'est pas du tout
ici je les fais en france en fait vous
voulez en est à l'américaine sur ok
alors kévin ce pays si m a dit qu a dit
qu'il avait été donc comment dire à
l'origine à harcèlement oui il ya
quelques années à de nombreuses années
et donc il a fait cette annonce là et
suite à cette annonce n'a pris que ça
décidé donc de mettre fin à la saison de
house of cards alors c'est un petit peu
compliqué au niveau d'une laming parce
que netflix avait déjà annoncé
globalement que la série allait
l'arrêter ce soir qu'elle n'avait pas
vraiment été fait de manière officielle
ils ont profité de ça pour dire voilà
maintenant alors je connais le timing
est un tout petit peu maladroit et je
trouve qu'on vit une drôle d'époque
aujourd'hui et je pense que c'est pas un
netflix
ça n'est pas aux réseaux sociaux ça
n'est pas aux médias finalement à
judiciariser les annonces et je pense
que si kevin ce pays ci doit être
accusés c'est la justice qui doit le
condamné et après netflix finalement
décidé d'arrêter la série
je pense que c'est un mélange de genres
qui est totalement malsain je trouve
aussi c'est vrai qu'ils se sont servis
de ça je pense pour arriver on est assez
d'accord c'est votre coup de gueule et
je le comprends
géraldine maillet